when rolling out fiber access networks i
think operators need to consider a
number of different things one is scale
for the future if anything over the last
few years has taught us it's that
bandwidth demands are somewhat
unpredictable and so if you're going to
build a fiber network one of the big
motivations of that is built through the
future one obvious way to do that is to
build for 10 gig fiber access networks i
think the second thing you'd look at is
well how about you know programmability
i need a network that's not only just
about higher speeds but i need a network
modern networks are more ad ai-driven
self-healing networks and then i think
the third aspect of that is efficiency
there's a lot of sustainability targets
which is also another major motivation
of all fiber networks
look at the products look at the
platforms the open disaggregated modern
platforms are much more efficient in
terms of the actual amount of power
consumption and space and everything
that it takes to deploy these products
versus large-scale legacy monolithic
chassis systems
[Music]